all right so yes I'm fully aware that I
still have to review the movie Tintin
and I will do that but at times like
this I feel it's important to reel it in
and concentrate on what's really
important in life like a trailer to The
Hobbit Bilbo Baggins I'm looking for
someone to share in an adventure
our first thing I found interesting in
this is that Ian Holmes in it for at
least a little bit I think that's really
cool cuz I heard he wasn't gonna be in
it at all because he's like dude I'm too
old to be doing this kind of stuff now
and then it goes back and it shows
Bilbo's adventures when he was younger
which really kind of negates that one
line that Gandalf said to Bilbo and
fellowship with a ring where he's all
like you haven't aged apparently he has
a few days actually and then you see all
the dwarves and what I really think is
cool is that all the dwarves don't look
like generic dwarves they don't all look
like Gimli you know they look unique
they look individual so puts the rumors
to rest right there no not all dwarves
look the same you racists but for me
when this really felt like Lord of the
Rings was this part right here
and then it kicks on with what I think
is the theme song which is pretty much
an orchestrated version of the song the
dwarves were just singing
and after that you're like yes this is
Lord of the Rings I mean looking at it
it has the same color scheme the same
tone as Lord of the Rings
I'm really glad Peter Jackson's
directing this movie because if he
wasn't I don't know that it would feel
exactly like Lord of the Rings Belt I'm
looking at this trailer you notice stuff
that you're like Rivendell but that
didn't happen which I think I see what
Peter Jackson's trying to do he's trying
to make it more or less fit into Lord of
the Rings more so he's gonna take a
little bit of artistic license but I do
have faith in the guy to an absurd
degree I think if j.r.r tolkien was here
right now he'd be like yeah it's okay ed
I trust Peter Jackson's vision it's fine
in the end if it all works out instead
of feeling like two Hobbit movies in
three Lord of the Rings movies it might
just feel like five Lord of the Rings
movies which I want that would be
awesome and we see Galadriel is in it
Cate Blanchett which is really
interesting and this really proves my
point that Cate Blanchett just gets
younger and hotter as time goes on she's
like The Curious Case of Cate Blanchett
she does not look ten years older in
this trailer than she did in Lord of the
Rings in fact she looks ten years
younger which kind of brings to light as
to why she was in The Curious Case of
Benjamin Button because she was like oh
yeah movie about someone like me well
that's cool I can get behind that yeah
and then the end happens and I was like
yes that's how you should end the
trailer give me promise that it will
come back no oh yeah it's right there if
Bilbo in the ring is not one of the most
fateful meetings in the history of
entertainment this next one is I love
Gollum people have asked me many times
Jeremy what's your favorite movie I will
say it right here right now my favorite
movie of all time is Lord of the Rings
and if you're about to ask yeah but
which one no all three of them are one
movie Lord of the Rings my favorite
movie of all time so I am absurdly
excited for The Hobbit movies it's
actually gonna be two movies an
unexpected journey and then there and
back again like I said take an artistic
license a little bit but if it works out
the way I think it should work out I
will be fine with it what do you think
about this Hobbit trailer are you
excited to see the Hobbit movies comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see Marvel Crosson more process